this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this week's episode Jonathan's taking a
look at the varied arsenal of Uncharted
4 and Uncharted the Lost Legacy so I
gather we are in India and I also gather
that this is called the insas which is a
real gun a real Indian service rifle
however this is not the incense this is
actually a Galil if there are any other
games guns and mechanics that you guys
want to see Jonathan breakdown let us
know in the comment section below and if
you'd like to help out the Royal
armories Museum and continue to support
Jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right
let's take a look at the weapons of
Uncharted
foreign
first impression is of the shooting
mechanics generally slightly exaggerated
shooting stance but some people do shoot
like that with the head counted over to
the side sort of lining up on their
right right arm the rate of fire on this
thing so it's three round burst that's
correct three round burst on rifles is a
bad idea generally on on fully automatic
pistols I think it's a very good idea
because if you if you have the need for
automatic fire from a handgun that's a
great way to prevent it just you losing
control of it because the rate of fire
of these things is so high that they're
just uncontrollable and you're shooting
the ceiling before you know it so you've
probably gathered from from the footage
and me talking that this thing does not
have a very high rate of fire and that's
my first issue it should be basically a
brap that's going on here and instead we
get a chugging low rate of fire in
tandem with rate of fire and recoil with
a machine pistol controllability so the
93r has a fold down foregrip and an
elongated trigger guard for your thumb
and that's superb for getting as much
control as you can out of a very compact
design shooting it like a conventional
pistol and it's somehow sedately still
pointing at the Target
we've got a nice external view here of
our protagonist with a Metabo revolver
so as people will probably know the
mataba is not just an interesting design
it's like called an auto revolver so
it's a little bit like the Webley
Fosbury that Cycles like a almost like a
self-loading pistol rather than relying
on the manual operation of pulling
through on the trigger although with the
hammer down you still have to fire it as
a double action revolver so the cylinder
revolves as you pull through on the
trigger and the hammer drops to fire the
first round and then itself [ __ ] so so
what should be happening is the hammer
Falls after the first shot anyway the
hammer Falls and the cylinder is
revolved and the hammer is actuated by
The Recoil of the of the weapon what
seems to be happening is the cylinder is
starting to revolve as the trigger is
pulled I may be misreading that but
that's my assessment in which case it
would be a little bit off right the
reload's quite interesting using the
other hand to push the cylinder through
to the other side to reload it something
a little bit than the usual flick it out
sideways reload it and flick it back in
it's ever so slightly
um idiosyncratic much like the gun
all right well this is a rare treat for
me a Flintlock firearm in a video game
they do exist but they're not by any
means common I have rushed to the
drawers and grabbed the closest thing
that I can lay my hands on there may be
something even closer in the collection
actually but this is pretty damn close
this one is English it's actually marked
London made by
Jova who is a UK based gun maker in the
18th century now this doesn't have the
Flint in the jaws of the [ __ ]
imagine if you will a piece of sharp
Stone in here because that's of course
how the flintlock works now the general
form of this matches what we see on
screen pretty well although there's a
barrel in on that one is a two-stage or
Spanish barrel where it starts out
faceted at the breach and then goes
round that's perfectly correct what's
not really correct is the flare of the
muzzle what this looks most like at the
muzzle is like a first world war flare
pistol and that may be what they've
modeled the flared out muzzle on the
reason that matters is that that would
be if that got knocked that would dent
it's a relatively minor issue this is
quite a good representation of a
flintlock pistol the two-handed Tactical
grip on it is amusing but I have five
different lock pistols using that grip
experimentally and it works very well
traditionally pistols were only ever
fired one-handed if if someone from the
18th or early 19th century saw you do
this with a pistol they would think you
were mad I'm sure unfortunately the
reload is completely glossed over I'll
just demonstrate this on the more robust
less fragile pistol that I've chosen so
we start in the firing position like
this
trigger is pulled the Flint that would
be in here scrapes off hot Sparks and
throws open the pan Sparks land in the
pan Flash and then boom that's how these
things work so we would end up in this
position what we then see is the main
character just reaches forward and
flicks the pan closed again I think at
the same time the [ __ ] is being somehow
manually automatically rather pushed
back so by doing that we somehow move
them both back well that's going to do
nothing that's not going to put any new
priming powder in your pan it wouldn't
bring the [ __ ] back and it absolutely
does not put powder and bullet down the
muzzle which is why it's called a muzzle
loader
[Music]
all right this is this is a very cool
addition clearly a a from the list a
collectible item called a lantern
mounted Flintlock so that I have seen
never in person but um in auction
catalogs online and so on and so forth
I've seen four Flintlock pistols with
lamps fitted to them so early early 19th
century early to mid 19th century
exciting prospect here is that we're
looking at a sort of almost
anachronistic item where you've got the
ability to shine a light and shoot a
bullet the monsters are definitely real
we're probably for
guarding warehouses that kind of thing
now this one I remember this coming up a
few years ago this is a very very good
virtual rendition of that real object
however the lamp on this thing is late
19th century whereas the lock on the gun
is Flintlock now the game takes place in
the present day so why wouldn't this
still be a thing but in terms of it
being a genuine sort of pirate artifact
or something it's too late for that but
for me as a historic arms person it's
it's very cool to see that represented
thank you
next one up
is sort of
a stay a solid fern
mp34 in some aspects very close to the
mp34 so the buttstop's sawn off okay and
you know anyone could do that to make it
more compact that would be a major
problem for accuracy but nonetheless and
various details are absolutely spot on
from what I can see the front sight
protectors the cooling jacket around the
barrel this distinctive architecture
around the top of the gun with the flip
up disassembly which I won't do for time
reasons that's all beautifully modeled
despite not being very visible from
third person but weirdly we have done
away with the relatively iconic side
mounted magazine of the mp34 that whole
bit of the receiver has been deleted and
the ejection Port filled in and a
different magazine located on the bottom
of the gun and the caliber of that looks
massive so suddenly we've got this it
sounds and behaves like a nine
millimeter submachine gun and that lack
of recoil even without the butt stock
these things pretty much the heavy
they're slow they stay put pretty well
when you're when you're shooting them on
automatic whatever this is chambered in
ought to be a real handful and it isn't
they've paid loving detail to a load of
detail on the gun and then they've made
major changes to it
[Music]
I do like the depiction of this grenade
launcher it sounds good it looks good
the area effect looks good maybe the
Fireballs are a bit much but the gun
itself is a bit of a head scratcher the
rotary drum magazine and kind of the
back end of the gun do look sort of M32
Mill core mgl but it appears to have a
pump grip on the front and general
proportions more like the experimental
China Lake grenade launcher this was
part of the program to having only just
invented the underbell grenade launcher
to create a multi-shot launcher so this
is a fictional weapon and I'm always a
bit surprised when games do both so we
have some pretty well represented real
world guns we then have some that are
really well done but then deliberately
changed up and then we have some
completely fictional weapon albeit and
stuff I inspired by at least two real
world real world grenade launches
this is the good old FN FAL or FAL if
you prefer specifically with this
metallic and round section handguard
which is the dead giveaway this is the
Israeli
incarnation of the fal I'm not sure
geographically whether this makes sense
as being in the game or not I'm also not
as okay with Israeli fals as I should be
to be able to say whether the
differences I'm seeing are legitimate or
not I can safely say that the top cover
is in fact wrong it should be this
classic almost steeple profile very
rounded shape not the squarish shape
that we see here bolt itself is rounded
here the bolt is quite square and blocky
where where I'm hazy would be with the
butt stock so our version has this
particular profile the version in the in
the game is continuing these machined
lines on the receiver into the top of
the butt stock are there any out there
that are like that I don't know maybe
now partly I suspect why the top cover
is wrong is that it's got a picatinny
rail built into it I guess somebody has
been buying on online or something and
has got a railed top cover so that the
game you can accessorize it a bit of a
bug bear of mine to change up classic
guns and fit Optics to them but in a
present day setting it's perfectly fine
but otherwise it's not a bad rendition
of this specific version of the FAL
SE
so the weapon we've got here I have
chosen this one purely because it's the
right color so the Beretta ARX 160 and
it is it's big it's chunky it looks that
way on screen it's very substantially
made of polymer and this one is brown
this has also got an updated rail system
that is machined aluminum and sits over
the top of the polymer shell now I don't
think the one in the game is is
representing that and it certainly isn't
representing the elephant in the room
here which is an AK magazine because
this one is a 7.62 by 39 caliber
Beretta now I I do like the way this is
behaving rate of fire seems about right
it has a sort of presence to it if it
doesn't sound too pretentious the
reload's a bit weird changing the
magazines with the right hand I think
he's got the cocking handle on the left
hand side maybe that's just his
preference as a left-hander and someone
who's perhaps not had rigorous military
training I don't know the character's
background to be fair
foreign
so I gather we are in India and I also
gather that this is called the insas
which is a real gun a real Indian
service rifle however this is not the
inside they are very similar guns to
look at and they have a shared lineage
but this is actually a Galil this is a
762 Galil arm I think looking at it so
it's you know if you squint they look
very very similar but the insas is
different in basically every detail it's
much more of a straight up AK receiver
remember rightly but it has a sort of
FAL inspired gas system and front end
suffice to say it's a real gun the
settings correct but this isn't the
right gun
maybe I'd fail to notice this on an
Uncharted 4 and it's the same there but
what we have in third person view aiming
down the sights is well not actually
aiming down the sides the character is
not properly shouldering the rifle and
is looking over the top of the gun
rather than trying for a cheek weld as
it's known for extra stability and
putting your eye directly behind the
sight there are parallels for this
Special Operations forces used to shoot
along these lines maybe more centrally
into the chest looking over the gun at
Close Quarters before we had good
Close Quarter battle Optics I suspect
that's a deliberate choice to let you
see more of what's going on with the gun
because we're not a first person shooter
and we can't see the gun model in front
of our face plus you have a slightly
better field of view around the
character if it's head gun rather than
head and guns together blocking half the
screen
that's our old friend the P90 now I have
the the wrong P90 grommet we have two
other P90s they are semi-auto only that
they have the type of sight that's on
the gun in the game that sits within
this housing whereas this is the more
modern rail adapted version and is also
fully auto and we've put a neotec on top
of it now that that's uh actually quite
problematic in that when I'm when I have
my cheek on the stock I can see through
the iron sight that's built into this
block but I have to do a bit of a chin
weld to see through the Red Dot side
however this character has a bigger
problem in that she is looking directly
over the top of the gun and not using
the sight at all seemingly it's a decent
model I think uh the we seem to have we
seem to have the classic P90 game gun
syndrome of not having the translucent
magazines that it's opaque you can't see
the bullets moving no cases visibly
ejecting that's correct because the P90
ejects
from the bottom you can see you through
the hole nice low dispersion of firing
this this is um extremely controllable
rate of fire might be a little slow the
real one is from memory
faster than this
so this is a Sega style AK 12 gauge
shotgun right AK based 12 gauge shotgun
with a drum magazine of course the way
it's modeled or animated I should say is
feels quite realistic because this
thing's got significant recoil if that's
box shot or slight one it's got I think
it's gonna be bug shot based on the
apparent spread it's bucking away like
crazy I'm not sure it's inaccurate
enough considering how much it's moving
around at the shooter's end it seems to
still be putting all of its shots in
roughly where you would want them to go
but at least you get the sense of
something powerful but hard to control
we do in terms of effects of this thing
we we are seeing people getting knocked
back quite drastically by a shotgun a
huge Trope of course from from movies
and similar things
you're welcome
we featured the Tavor on this series a
number of times I think I don't think
I've ever shown you this one this is an
Indian x95 I know that because well
because it was sold to us as such and
because it has i n on the magazine why
is it identified iron on the magazine
well weirdly the magazine I don't have
another one to compare but um is
actually slightly longer front to back
Indian 5.56 ammunition is ever so
slightly longer so this is actually
specifically an Indian gun even though
it's not marked as such now as I as I
understand we are in India for the for
this game I assume that's not a
coincidence and this is meant to be an
Indian x95 admittedly it is in desert
tan but yeah other than that it's this
gun
so if you'd like to come and visit us at
one of our three Royal armories museums
here in the UK we would love you to do
so check out our various social media
accounts you can find those via website
we do have our own YouTube channel that
you might like to slide on over to and
thanks again for watching guys see you
next week
[Music]